das heißt die
Herausforderungen
also Lage und Optionen nenne ich das mal
zunächst mal der Klimawandel ist real
erst weitgehend Mensch gemacht und den
Maßen steuerbar durch die Emission von
Treibhaus
das Konzept der Kipppunkte auf die man
sich ja dass man sich ja hier immer
wieder bezieht ist akademisch attraktiv
schönes Thema
durch die Analyse der bestehenden Lage
kaum Unterstützung wenn Sie den ICC
Bericht gucken
in Hamburg der genau in dem Bereich
mitgearbeitet hat die haben sich mit dem
Thema auseinandergesetzt ist nicht
einfach so dass der nichts steht weil
sich nicht umgekümmert haben sondern
haben das ist nicht aktuell aber das
Thema ist politisch wirksam da könnte
man aber auch immer reden wieso
eigentlich
den deutschen Beitrag zum Klimawandel
Ansehen
in der Sonne nicht pro Kopf aber für den
Klimawandel geht es nur um die Summe
nicht um Gerechtigkeit wer das CO2
Molekül raus lässt dann Bäcker aus
Berlin oder jemand in Vietnam ist egal
für das Thema
dann der Klimawandel kann nicht gänzlich
vermieden werden ist der teilweise auch
schon da und an Endpunkt des Anstieg ist
der globalen Mitteltemperatur wenn wir
das mal als Proxy nehmen als Indikator
für den Klimawandel von 1,5 oder zwei
Grad wie ein gigantischer Erfolg aber
immerhin sind ja zwei Grad dann schon im
Sack
das wirtschaftliche System das hinter
den weltweiten Emissionen steht
industrieverkehr Energie und
mikroklimate also Heizung Kühlung ist
Felge und nur auf Zeitskalen von
Jahrzehnten also nicht nicht sehr viel
aber einigen Jahrzehnten veränderbar
der wichtige Punkt ist da die
Treibhausgasemissionen in ihrer Summe
wirken es ist die Summe und nur die ist
für das Thema interessant
kann eine merkbare Steuerung des
globalen Mensch gemachten Klebeband ist
nur gelingen wenn die großen Emittenten
teilnehmen also China Indien USA EU
können darüber verhandeln wieder alles
mitnehmen
innovative aber isolierte Maßnahmen die
in Deutschland zu Emissionsminderung
implementiert werden bleiben weitgehend
wirkungslos zu werden diese nicht für
Nachahmung durch andere Akteure führt
also wenn andere Leute ist der
nachmachen
aber wie kann man das hinkriegen diese
Nachahmung ich meine nur durch
ökonomische Vorteile was meinen Sie mit
ökonomische Vorteile es muss sich lohnen
also ich muss ja ich mein Leben muss
irgendwie besser sein es muss ein
bisschen mehr so sein Hollywood Film
sie wollen die Klimakrise wie ein
Hollywood-Film die Menschen Indien in
China und sonstwo und Nigeria die wollen
ein besseres Leben haben und das kriegen
sie unter anderem vorgeführt von
Hollywood Film es interessiert gar nicht
was die jungen Leute hier machen
entscheidend ist was die Menschen
draußen in der Welt machen da die eben
auch für den meisten Teil Emissionen
beantwortet sind dass wir eine ganze
Menge isoliert imitiert haben ist klar
und die einzig konsequente Antwort von
unserer Seite wäre die freigesetzten
Gase wieder reinzuholen dann würden wir
natürlich unsere Schuld abarbeiten aber
keiner Flensburg
das CO2 in den Boden sollte
also wie können wir ökonomische Kinder
also darum dass wir ökonomische Vorteile
indiziert werden und nicht moralische
oder politische Ansprüche also sie
wollen das ökonomische Vorteile für
Nigeria Indien China und andere Länder
möchten die Menschen dort dass sie sagen
ja das lohnt sich für mich und zwar so
wie sie es meinen nicht so wie ein
Mensch in ich glaube das Kreuz hier in
Deutschland wie sehen sie wie schätzen
Sie das ein übertreiben wir in
Deutschland gibt es eine Historie oder
ja Sie dürfen noch sagen ja gerne
also technologische Innovationen ja
schon mir die einzige realistische
Perspektive eine ökonomischen motivierte
Nachahmung Bekannten aus was zu
erreichen also zum Beispiel dass die
Menschen in China sagen ja ich will ein
Auto haben und ich bin bereit ein
Elektroauto zu fahren
Maße deshalb weil es einfach billiger
ist
weil das ganz ganz viele Punkte sind
sehr gute referieren aber sind so viele
verschiedene Punkte Elektroautos
beispielsweise sind ja auch nicht ohne
jegliche Kritik oder das kann man gut
eine Kritik daran leisten und da würde
ich auch vorstellen dass wir natürlich
sehr schön wenn es uns gelingen würde
unser wesentlichen Ressorts in diesem
Land nämlich technisches Wissen dafür zu
sorgen dass die Umweltbelastung durch
die Entwicklung und Elektroautos
geringer wird
so das sind also die Hauptpunkte das
noch mal zusammen oder was also der
Mensch gemacht der Klimawandel ist eine
reale Herausforderung muss politisch
verhandelt werden
sowohl im Hinblick auf die Minderung der
Missionen als auch auf die unvermeidbare
Anpassung das heißt der einzige der hier
in der Runde habe ich den Eindruck was
ordentlich dazu also qualifiziert das
sozusagen verstehen
nicht dabei ist die entscheidende Frage
die eben zum Beispiel von Futures und
von Generation nicht gestellt wird die
nach der Wirksamkeit von Maßnahmen
sowohl bei der Anpassung als auch beim
an bei der Behinderung der Mission die
Wissenschaft kann helfen festzustellen
welche Maßnahmen wie wirksam sind wenn
ich dies tue kriege ich jenes also wenn
wir mal einen Corona Beispiel nehmen
würden wir können eben sagen wenn wir
die Kontakte unter den Menschen
einschränken dann können wir die
Verbreitung des Virus und so
einschränken aber diese arme Virologe
kann ich sagen welche Folgen das hat für
die Kinder die nicht mehr zur Schule
gehen und aber es gehört zum Problem
dazu
Wissenschaft alleine
denken verschiedene Experten mit
reinholen und wissenschaftlich Disziplin
welche Maßnahmen politisch zu wählen
sind das ist eine politische
Entscheidung und die gesellschaftliche
Willensbildung berücksichtigt die
wissenschaftliche Einschätzung also dass
solche wenn wir sagen würde das
funktioniert nicht alle in der Nase
wurden singt daraufhin nicht der CO2
Gehalt aber sie entscheidet in der
politische Abwägung und Logik und das
dafür haben wir ja Politik diesen
Prozess der hier eine ein Ausgleich von
gesellschaftlichen Interessen wollen wir
einmal die Debatte eröffnen weil ich
glaube wir können uns gar nicht alle
Punkte am Tisch nach einander merken und
Herr steht mir wurde ja schon gebeten zu
antworten
er ist viel mehr im Zentrum des
Interesse ist in der Zeit im Zentrum des
Tuns als irgendein harmloser
durchaus in manchen zu was Sie gesagt
haben zum einen muss man sagen wir haben
ein Problem mit dem Menschen gemacht den
Klimawandel das kann man auch nicht
bestreiten das sagen einem die
Wissenschaftler wir müssen da was tun
unsere Kinder und Engel haben das
gleiche Recht wie wir selbst in
Wohlstand und Frieden zu leben meine
Generation ist die erste dieser tun
dürfen unsere Aufgabe ist dafür zu
sorgen dass das so bleibt nun heißt das
nicht und wir haben viele Fehler in der
Vergangenheit gemacht du hast das nicht
wir können jetzt zum Beispiel Chinesen
oder erinnern oder sagen verzichte die
dir mal bitte auf Wachstum weil das ist
für die Welt unter das geht nicht ja was
ich immer als Beispiel wir haben eine
große Industriegesellschaft in
Deutschland wir sind das
viertgrößchenindustrie Land wenn wir
weltweit wenn wir in der Lage wären
unsere Industrie die übrigens sehr viel
höheren Energiebedarf hat
als das im privaten Bereich gilt so
umzubauen dass die klimaneutral wird
wenn wir zeigen wie das geht technisch
zeigen wie das geht und es auf eine
Weise machen die sozialverträglich
anders geht es in Demokratie nämlich
nicht dann würde das die Chinesen
deutlich eher überzeugen wie was der
Vergangenheit über uns wissen als wenn
wir in moralische Vorträge halten so ist
das übrigens im Inneren genauso ich
finde diese moralische Stellen Alarm
also sind ja nicht immer ja ich muss ihn
ehrlich sagen ich will was Positives
sagen kann man nicht immer sagen über
die deutsche Wirtschaft wenn sie mit
großen Konzern Chefs heute reden die
nicht mehr über die Frage ob sie das
machen wollen sondern wie die Regierung
verhandelt außer sie mit ihnen über
Rahmenbedingungen wie man das hinkriegen
kann die meisten haben das sehr wohl
begriffen die wissen dass sie keine
Autos mehr verkaufen können die die Luft
verpesten dass ich das ändern muss die
wissen dass wir technologische
unterschiedliche Wege gehen müssen wenn
ich völlig verdrottelt ist weiß das und
deswegen sage ich mal ist es eine
Aufgabe wo das Management natürlich oder
nicht
Deutschland keine Autos mehr verkaufen
das alleine überzeugt mich jetzt nicht
natürlich kann Deutschland das nicht
lösen aber Deutschland ein großes
Industrieland wir sind Technologie mäßig
so gut haben Ingenieure haben
Wissenschaft dass wir in der Lage sein
müssten in manchen Bereichen auch
Weltmarktführer zu werden das dann auch
hier zu produzieren neben mir unser
Anteil ist wie hoch der deutsche Anteil
CO2
ja das weiß ich das aber alleine ist
doch keine Antwort das geht ja in jedem
Mal wenn sie sagen ach das lohnt sich
gar nicht dass ich mich irgendwie ändere
weil es macht mir nicht genug das kann
sein Demokratie nicht sein da darf nur
nicht Illusion haben dass das reicht ich
sag trotzdem noch mal wenn ein Land wie
Deutschland größte Land in Europa riesen
Industrieland mit all den Möglichkeiten
die wir haben zeigt wie das geht
technisch und nicht anderen Vorträge
hält ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das
umgesetzt wird und das ist weltweit gute
Entwicklungen deutlich höher und ich
halte überhaupt nichts davon überzeugt
zu reden den Leuten irgendwas zu
predigen moralpredigen sondern er taucht
uns auch nach außenwürdiglich nichts
sondern in der realen Welt anzusetzen
sich mit den realen gegeben heiten zu
beschäftigen und das zu tun was Sie tun
können da sind wir deutlich unter
unseren Möglichkeiten
hat zu Recht gesagt
Industriegesellschaft ist die größte
industrielle Aufgabe die wir in den
letzten 100 Jahren hatten und das müssen
wir erstmal hinkriegen und das ist eine
gewaltige Aufgabe die kann man nicht so
eben Schultern und wir haben natürlich
durch den Ukraine Krieg auch
Rückschritte wir haben Kohlekraftwerke
wieder ins Netz gebracht worden
und Politiker ihren Chef loben dürfen
aber ich würde gerne ich würde gerne
einmal ähm Kissler noch kurz in die
Debatte reinholen ähm ja vielleicht darf
ja auch ein Journalist dann doch was ich
will natürlich kein Klima klimaforce
im Bundestag aber ich sage meine Steuern
hier ich finde es immer erfrischend wenn
man hört wir müssen überzeugen durch
Technik und durch Leistung und möchte
ich Moral also dieses Appell zum
realistischen finde ich sehr frischen
und wird auch in ihrer Partei und bei
dem grünen schon gar nicht nicht immer
beherzigt dann haben allerdings durch
den blinden Fleck und dann kann ich
natürlich ganz ersparen der Kernkraft
ich bin jetzt gerade in Finnland gewesen
und da war die interessante Koinzidenz
das am selben Wochenende an dem
Deutschland aus der Kernkraft für immer
oder vorübergehend wer weiß es schon
ausgestiegen ist wurde dort ein
Kernkraftwerk eröffnet und dann hat er
zuständige Minister glaube ich gesagt
das ist zentraler Bestandteil unserer
grünen Klimawende die Eröffnung dieses
Kernkraft und auch hammer groß sieht das
so und auch Herr Todor hat jetzt Herrn
Scholz ein Kanada einen kleinen Vortrag
gehalten warum man eigentlich für die
Klimawende Kernkraftwerke bräuchte also
ich glaube überzeugen durch Leistung und
Realismus bin ich ganz bei Ihnen aber
man könnte auch durch die realistische
Einschätzung und durch die Leistung
deutscher kernwerkstechnologie
überzeugen und dass man sich ich möchte
mal wirklich sagen ohne Not einer so
schwierigen Situation jetzt um eben den
Grünen diesen Fetisch das Kernkraft
ausstiegens zu geben sich von dieser
Technologie verabschiedet dafür habe ich
ihn haben viele andere sogar die
Mehrheit der Deutschen kein Verständnis
da darf ich ihn widersprechen
selbstverständlich weil die Atomkraft
ist die teuerste Energie Sachen die wir
jemals hatten das muss ich Jahrtausende
bewacht werden der radioaktive Müll das
gilt für keine andere Energieform wir
haben in Harrisburg wir haben in
Tschernobyl gesehen wir haben in
Fukushima gesehen was passiert bei der
Techniker die der Mensch nicht
beherrschen war keine Fehler machen und
ein schlimmere kommt noch dazu es
blockiert auch noch die erneuerbaren
Energien von denen wir dringend mehr
brauchen die französischen ja fast die
Hälfte still weil die Flüsse nicht mehr
hier ständig stehen
wahnsinnig teuer zahlen wir Steuerzahler
sie und ich eine für eine gefährliche
Technik das ist nicht die Lösungen
von vorgestern
richtig gemacht haben dass sie nämlich
gesagt haben wir haben die Möglichkeiten
zu zeigen wie man klimaneutral zum
Beispiel Dinge gemacht das heißt sind
meinen Worten eigentlich interessiert
ist gar nicht so sehr wie viel wir die
Emissionen in Deutschland weil es mich
ziemlich wenig sind sondern dass wir
demonstrieren wie man das machen kann
und das muss man sich vorführen und bei
der Gelegenheit mindern wir auch unsere
Mission aber das wichtigste ist
tatsächlich nicht die visionsbindung
selbst sondern das Entwickeln von
Methoden diese überall auf der Welt zu
mindern und dass man dann auf den
Trichter kommen könnte wir haben ja doch
erhebliche Fortschritte gemacht bei
nicht wir also die Ingenieure haben
schon gemacht bei der Kerntechnik das
ist ja nicht so dass wir immer noch die
kern-technischen Anlagen haben gegen
seinerzeit wahrscheinlich demonstriert
haben inzwischen gibt's ja neue und
möglicherweise sind die doch wirklich
wesentlich mehr geeignet und von
Jahrhunderttausenden ist da gar nicht
mehr die Rede sondern von deutlich
weniger Sachen ob das denn stimmt sei
mal dahingestellt aber immerhin wir
könnten daran unseren Gehirnschmalz
reinstecken und das ist eigentlich die
Aufgabe wir sollen unser Gehirnschmalz
reinstecken zu zeigen wie kann man das
machen so dass es sich lohnt im Sinne
von Lebensqualität von den Menschen die
betroffen sind und nicht von den
Kreuzberg